Why is it Called a “Medicine Ball”?
Medicine balls, for those of you who haven’t
been to a gym or never accidentally kicked
one thinking it was like a soccer ball (true
story), are heavy weighted balls coming in
a variety of sizes and weights (with the biggest
we could find ringing in at a whopping 150
pounds) with a diverse range of fitness applications.
But why exactly are they called medicine balls
when, at its core, a medicine ball is just
a big heavy ball?
For starters, medicine balls are noted to
be one of the most diverse pieces of exercise
equipment one can own, useful for toning almost
every part of the body, and are also extensively
used in various forms of physical therapy.
While details are sparse on the history of
medicine balls, we can reliably track their
usage back around 3000 years, where they were
used by Persian wrestlers looking to become
stronger.
In Ancient Greece, Hippocrates considered
them to be an essential tool for helping injured
people regain mobility and he advised people
to use them as a general, all purpose way
of remaining healthy.
This all brings us back to the origin of the
name.
The word “medicine” was long synonymous
with the word “health”.
For example, it’s noted that Renaissance
physician Hieronymus Mercurialis advised that
people of all fitness levels should use what
we would recognise as medicine balls in his
book De Arte Gymnastica, as part of what he
called “medicinal gymnastics“.
The use of the word “medicinal” in this
case was to highlight how the exercises could
be used as both a way of healing injuries
and preventing them in the first place through
general fitness.
Although devices we would recognise as being
medicine balls have been commonplace for millennia,
the word itself is only a few hundred years
old, being attributed to one, Professor Roberts
way back in 1889.
According to a Scientific American article
from the time, Roberts coined the term “medicine
ball” in reference to the fact that using
the ball “invigorates the body, promotes
digestion, and restores and preserves one’s
health“.
As “health” and “medicine” were considered
to be synonymous terms at the time, calling
it a “medicine ball” was natural enough.
Today, we still refer to medicine balls as
such, even though the terms “health” and
“medicine” aren’t as synonymous as they
once were.
“Health ball” also doesn’t quite have
the same ring
to it.